Gregg Achara we're gonna watch how it
should have ended well I didn't create
it I'll take the credit sure yeah you've
seen these guys right hizzy yes their
health they're hysterical one of the
best YouTube channels of all the time
let's see if how should have ended could
you might improve it yes clowns children
[Music]
I got it all right losers
it's got Beverly trapped in this house
no I know your first instinct is to stay
here and let me go in all by myself but
what did I tell you that's right we all
stick together is everyone ready ready
I'm serious now I don't want to turn
around and see you guys wandering off by
yourselves everyone sticks together to
fight the crazy shape-shifting clowns
right right let's do this unreal when
it's useful maybe that's it because
something else pick it up
is thinking any worse not by our
calculations
we wouldn't want you to come back in 27
years and kill more people now that's
for sure right kids
that'll be $5,000 here we go ha ha if
you just leave us be now take him only
him you know what this is dumb I'll just
take all of you right now that was easy
of
way there might be a stinger
[Music]
hey everyone its Tina from how it should
have ended there
now we're not strangers we want to thank
audible for sponsoring this episode
we'll bring all of you a free audiobook
just go to audible.com slash hizzy or
text the word h i sh e - 500 500 there
is a huge selection of titles on audible
includes a high level or even key summer
is road trip time for his lots of
conventions about listening to a horror
novel and the audiobook it by Stephen
King is no exception totally recommended
so go check it out or pick out another
amazing audio book for free at
audible.com/asap
to start your trial everyone to do it
thank you that's the YouTube buyer right
this how it should have ended really
played on the stupid decisions the kids
make in the movie but then it wouldn't
be a movie if you didn't make stupid
decision especially a horror movie yeah
what I loved about the movie scream was
when they cold it out and they're like
why does the girl always one up the
stairs and down the stairs and out the
house like well yeah cuz it wouldn't be
a horror movie yeah exactly I mean like
even with the kid and the boat I feel
like in the context of it you're like a
kid and a clown kind of makes sense but
then when you see something like this
you're like yeah our kids kind of stupid
yeah dumb kid I feel like any kid will
run away from a creepy-looking clown
there's in the sewer but those the boat
don't you need it right the boat back
yeah or even with the projector I saw
the joke coming yeah plug it yeah
that's like the obvious thing you do in
that moment in real life you just be
like no I try to discern myself like as
an adult and a kid but then I think like
well when I was a kid I feel like I
would have made the smarter decision and
not have gone through with something I
like I think kids run away when
something scary is happening not let me
go find out you know to be fair in
Beverly's case if I was a kid and
something scary was going on be like mom
dad I think her dad was actually a
monster as well so yeah in that
situation it's like well what's the
lesser of two evils there is that I
might've been able to like debunk some
of this how it should have ended if I if
I remember the movie a little bit early
because I stopped at one time in the
theaters when it says that how it
actually ended I loved how first of all
how brief it is here yeah because
normally and these how it should have
ended its long that's like the one they
spend the most time on but here who is
just like what it's all is all penny
wise had to do because I remember they
also like kicking the crap out of him
yeah and then when I watch this I'm like
oh yeah could've done that right because
that's he took control over Beverly yeah
so you could have done the exact same
thing here I don't know why he didn't do
that they all decided not to be afraid
at the same time because you know he
wants to do expositional dialogue we're
not afraid anymore just turn fear off
yeah that's just a switch emotions are
just a switch never forget that people
any emotion you feel is not subconscious
you are strictly choosing to feel that
way here is a choice fears choice and so
are all other emotions they're all
choice hmm you are not entitled to any
of them anyway this is still a really
funny video though man they do a great
job at doing this animation spoofs with
also making you go that's true yeah
that's true
I really enjoyed the joke ending in the
beginning where they just had all over
like a tease coach for the pop culture's
are the Batman the Ghostbusters a turtle
yeah that's great house a lair
yeah of course that the Ghostbusters
could come they key just tera Pennywise
there wouldn't even be an issue anymore
that's a movie waiting to happen the
Ghostbusters crosses over with Pennywise
yeah that's a million-dollar idea right
there yeah literally just 1 million
dollar budget so you can subscribe to
the reject nation click that
notification bell a chars on the Jacke
my senior charas channel I mean I have a
channel but you'll find me more yeah I
go on the get you have E channel people
link in description box you know what to
do subscribes and all that we'll see you
guys on the flippity squatty